hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game 11 of the 2021 world chess
championships being held in dubai
between madness carlson and jan nepo now
madness carlson has six and a half
points coming into today meaning he's
only one point away or one victory away
or two draws
from being the world champion yet again
his opponent yannepo three and a half
points has some catching up to though
needs essentially a miracle needs to win
three of the next four games just to tie
and take it to
tie breakers but it all starts here for
yon nepo he has the white pieces has to
make something happen he starts out with
e4 madness crosstalk responds e5 knight
f3 knight c6 bishop to c4 the italian
game love the italian game curious to
see what variation they choose
knight to f6 and then d3
bishop to c5 now this is the gioco piano
but the d3 variation
is considered
a very quiet game it's very drawlish
it's really a slow game which not
something you would expect to see when
white really has to be going for a win
but that's exactly what we see pawn two
c3
pawn d6 from madness carlson castle on
the king side a5 so magnus charleston
pushing on the queen side here rook to
e1 getting this rook involved to the
center of the board here bishop swings
back to a7 still maintaining the
pressure on this long dark square
diagonal you can see the pawn here on f2
definitely a weakness even after the
castle the king is the only piece
defending that pawn knight 2 a3 and then
after pawn to h6 just
keeping it base some of the white pieces
the knights typically would come to
g5 as well as the bishop coming here to
g5 stops both of those one of the
biggest threats you have in the italian
game which who knows if we would
actually see it is the move knight to g5
with the knight and the bishop both
attacking this pawn on f7 since both of
these pawns have already moved from
madness carlson e5 and d6 we definitely
have to move an additional piece uh to
stop the threat here on f7 you usually
don't want to be moving your pawns
multiple times but we definitely need to
do that to stop the threat here on f7
but we don't see that h6 stops that
threat here and then knight to c2 could
have just played knights b5
that's completely fine as well attacking
the bishop you know bishop to b6 is
going to be fine as well but instead
janepo decides to go ahead and play
knight to c2 have to maneuver it around
from the beginning could not play just
knight two c3 since his pawn is here so
playing the a3 and now c2 gonna swing
over here to e3 at some point madness
crossing castle on the king side bishop
to e3 says hey do you want to change
spanish crosston says absolutely knight
takes here on e3 and then rook to e8 so
manage carlson doing the same thing
getting his rooks towards the center of
the board to just help control
the center this pawn here on e5
definitely wants to maintain that
pressure he has
pawn to a4 so just counter attacking on
the queen side is jannepo
bishop to e6 says hey do you want to
just trade off bishops yeah completely
fine and that's typically what you'll
see in these type of games where it's
not open none of the ponds have come off
the board and these type of games the
knights are actually going to fare
better so they just decide hey let's go
ahead and get the bishops off the board
we're not going to be using those as
much and now we have the knights
last piece for white to get involved
into the game is the queen so queen to
b3 attacking the pawn here on b7 then we
have b6 rook to d1 and then knight to e7
if you start to look at the moves
madness carlson has here as far as
developing this material
he doesn't really have a ton of great
options he could play rook comes back
here to e8 um okay that's completely
fine he could play queen d7 but many
times if you don't have a great move you
got to be thinking about what your
opponent going to be trying to do this
knight on c6 it doesn't have a lot of
great squares it has an outpost here on
d4 but that's defended by this pawn here
on c3
and even if it comes to e7 you say well
you can't really come down to f5 and d5
because both of those are being attacked
by the pawn that is true
but
once the knight comes back here to e7 it
allows magnus carlson to stop some of
the threats that white has and that's
coming to
d5 or f5 which are great outposts for
white so he's playing more defensive
right now with the knight to e7 because
he doesn't have any other strong moves
as far as development somewhat playing
defensive again madness carlson man he's
smart he knows how to win these
championships and he recognizes i just
have to get two more draws and i am
going to be the champion so hey let's
just play it safe here knight t7 does
that pawn set h3 says yeah uh if your
knight comes down here to uh g4 stop
some of that threat don't really see
that happening right now the bishop the
light square bishop can't come and also
the knight here on e3 was already
protecting that but h3 also opens up if
the king ever needs to come to h2 you
definitely don't want to have all your
pawns just blocking your king you don't
have to worry about any back rank make
mate or anything like that after you
play h3
queen two a d7 and then knight comes
back here to h2 another thing that the
pawn on h3 does allows the knight to
maneuver a little bit so rook to d8
just bringing it to the center of the
board here and then knight to uh g4
madness crossman says yeah if you want
to change off material that's completely
fine with me so they do see the exchange
here and then the pawn takes on a g4 one
of the ideas here is we need to swing
the rook over to h1 at some point
hopefully they get get behind enemy
lines giannipo just trying to find any
sort of initiative that he can possibly
have here pawn to d5 manage carlson says
yeah let's go ahead and blow up the
center of the board i don't want you to
be working your way towards the king
side of the board so let's keep things
towards the center here pawn to d4 we do
see the exchange on the d file
and then rook down to e4
attacking this pawn right here also
defending the pawn on d4
and the rook coming to e4 probably
more advisable than knight taking here
on d5 things get pretty complicated
after rook takes on d4
you can see a lot of the pressure on
this knight here with the pawn pushing
forward to c4 then the knights being
pinned down not great knight can't move
right now the queen falls so maybe pawn
to c5 uh attacking this rook but then
after the rook comes back here how does
black really respond maybe pawn to c4
stopping the pawn from pushing forward
but then the queen just takes you you're
losing material here you still have this
knight being pinned down you have now
the knight the rook and the queen
attacking it so madness carlson
correctly plays rook to e4 instead of
taking that pawn menace crossman just
hasn't really made too many errors in
this entire tournament
queen to c2
then we see rook to
uh f4 since it's being attacked by the
queen here and then we see
a huge
blunder
from white unfortunately yanepo does it
again he really needed to in this
position play something like rook takes
here on d4 and then there is going to be
a flurry of exchanges and that's not
exactly what he wants you don't want to
go into the end game
with no advantage at all because it's
very difficult to
figure any sort of initiative against
manuscripts especially since you already
have the double pawns here on the g file
because from here the pawn takes knight
takes you can start to see even more
exchanges potentially the queen takes on
c7
you just
are exchanging material and there's no
end in sight for you to to win but
uh unfortunately he plays the move g3
and just does not really think about all
of the threats in the game because yes
this pawn is attacking the rook
but the pawn taking here on e3 this is a
deadly move from magnus carlson pawn
takes the rook yes material advantage
for white in that exchange but after the
queen takes on g4
the threats are very difficult for white
to deal with the king comes back to f1
queen 2 h3 check king 2 g1
madness crossing has some couple options
here if you
watch the stream or you kind of run your
own analysis here it says that the best
move is pawn takes here on f2
and then the queen takes here
and then rook to d6 with the thought of
the rook swinging over here to
g6 that's kind of the idea uh i i don't
think it's quite this easy though for
madison carlson he's we're at move 26
right now uh he didn't have as much time
as i think he would have liked and
there's some complications going on you
don't know exactly
you know how things would look
uh
you know after rook two d6 you have to
start thinking about okay pawn to f5
does that stop it okay well the road
can't swing over here right now how how
would i continue uh maybe queen to f1
just attacking the queen remember in the
exchange
white did better got the rook just gave
up at night and so has to make sure he
still always has the
advantage you could always look at queen
2 g2 i think madness carlson was just
analyzing all those positions said i'm
not 100 confident that this is
so much better than just playing this
safer route and that is the move the
knight to f5 which i really like from
madness carlson i think it's intuitive
and i think it still maintains a lot of
the pressure uh if you know the pawn
takes here
he always has the threat of the knight
coming down either taking this material
coming here to g3 with many threats as
well um and so i i felt like just
getting more material involved into the
game i feel like is the safer approach
so from here we see d6 white recognizes
that one of the main threats is the rook
to d6 swing over to g6 and so he stops
that right away with pawn to d6
knight to h4 with the threat of queen to
g2 checkmate so definitely have to stop
that first stops it with pawn takes here
on e3 so that the queen can now protect
that square here on g2
now madness carlson plays queen g3 check
you know obviously not gonna see queen
two g2 stopping that because that's just
going to be a mate right there instead
we see king 2 f1
and then knight 2 f3 followed by queen
to f2 uh and and the threat's just too
much so yes you could take the pawn here
on a c7
attacking the rook here on d8 but just
catastrophic it's going to be over after
queen 2 g1 check and then queen to g2
checkmates who really has to stop it
with the queen plays queen to f2 uh
queen two h3 check queen two g2 and now
decides to go ahead and exchange here
anytime maddis crossman is trading off
his queen
you know things are definitely going to
go poorly for you especially with the
exposed king here so after the king
takes knight takes here on e1 rook takes
and then rook takes on d6 so uh madness
carlson says you know i'm gonna play it
safe getting into the end game i'm up
upon the material i can execute this
all day long
and he's probably calculated to the t
exactly how to do that in the end game
he's just not going to lose he just has
such a huge advantage here he feels
pretty confident that he can win this
100 times out of 100 so why take any
risk king 2 f3 trying to get that king
involved into the game rook down to d2
anytime you have a rook
in the end game you want to get it to
your opponent's second rank if you're
black or white if you want to get up to
the seventh rank usually because you can
get behind enemy lines usually all the
pawns have not moved yet so you can
start to to chip away and start to gain
some material on your opponent rook to
be one just playing defense not exactly
where you want to be if you're young
nepo
pan 2 g6 pawn up here to b4 we do see
the exchange right here uh but then rook
over here to a2
threatening this pawn
again just playing uh defense here king
to e4 pawn h5 madness carlson has these
past pawns on the king side and it is
going to be very difficult to deal with
king 2 d5 and this is you know another
mistake from jannepo just not exactly
what he needs to do here because rook to
c2
and this just makes it very very clear
that white's not going to be able to
come over here
and defend this pawn from pushing
forward here to h1 rook now has to
support
and the rook here on
b3
pawn to h4 king up to c6 i need to
gobble up some of this material but
doesn't matter pawn to h3
king takes pawn down h2 just pushing
those pawns as much as possible
and then
rook to b1 gobbles up this material here
on c3 and then after the king takes on
b6 probably my favorite move and a
fitting way to end the world
championship madness carlson plays the
move rook to
b3 sacrificing
this rook here on b3 it's check so you
pretty much have to take
yonepo being a good sport about it takes
it and still plays on a little bit
longer pawn to h1
getting that queen
pawn to a5 and then playing queen to e4
i like this move again uh from madness
carlson you know allowing his opponent
to make more mistakes i feel like every
single move he does is just allowing his
opponent to hang himself because you
could see a6 here that would lose to
queen to e6 check and then after the
king moves the rook is going to fall
beyond epo not going to do that instead
plays king 2 a7
queen 2
e7 check
king 2 a8
and then king 2 g7
not many moves longer rook two b6 and
then magnus cross in plays queen two
c
five and you can see the thread here uh
really this is attacking both the pawn
here on a5 as well as
the rook
not too worried about the rook here he's
not going to change the queen for the
rook but where does the rook really move
from here he wants to play something
like rook to a6 potentially to
just stop
the queen from taking here
okay but then your your pawn is stopped
here and so madness carlson can just
start pushing on this king side of the
board the road can't go anywhere else
though can't come to c6 or d6 because it
would just get gobbled up by the queen
can't come to
e6 here and so all of a sudden his
options are to move the rook
or just
lose this pawn if he wants to come
anywhere else that's not where you want
to be and who realizes this game is is
over so he resigns madness carlson gets
the victory with the black pieces and
the best of 14 series is over manas
crosstalk retains his title seven and a
half points to three and a half points
an absolute dominant dominant
performance from manus carlson uh i feel
pretty bad for yanepo because on a good
day
i think he is just as good as magnus
carlson on his best though best day he
has shown that he's actually better but
managed carlson
there's no denying how good this guy is
and in the world championship series
he's just the best and if we go back to
game six the the longest game
ever in a world championship series
madness carlson just drained his
opponent i think and after that yon
nippo realized man i don't think i can
play at this high level uh and that
almost just destroyed
internally everything that yonepo had so
after that it was kind of downhill
continued to make mistakes magnus
carlsen capitalized and he is victorious
so hopefully you guys enjoyed the series
it's been a fun couple weeks
covering this some really fun play
madness carlson well deserving champion
but thank you guys so much for watching
the video i appreciate the support of
the channel if you wouldn't mind hitting
that like button definitely helps the
channel out a lot and let me know in the
comments what you thought of
the series
i know hopefully many of you have
watched
multiple videos that we've put out so
just curious feedback
for me for the channel of the coverage
anything that can help improve uh for
future videos that would definitely be
appreciated so thank you guys so much
for
watching and the support and i'll see
you guys next time
you